[Applause]
Colin and Che and millions of people
only watching to see if I bring up Kanye
I don't apologize first time in my life
Saturday Night Live says goodbye to some
long time greats the season finale
features special tributes to Pete
Davidson and Kate McKinnon so are you
officially leaving yeah man Lauren
accidentally gifted me a sock so I'm
free
plus cast members Kyle Mooney and Eddie
Bryant also exit the iconic series I
truly am taking it one minute at a time
it's definitely where I've grown up
while chatting with Colin Jost on a
weekend update Pete reflects on his
first year as a cast member I never
imagined this would be my life you know
I mean look at me when I started here
like back then I was just like a skinny
kid and no one knew what race I was
and like now everyone knows I'm white
because I became hugely successful while
barely showing up to work
and like look at me now I'm aging like
an old banana
and Colin still looks like the only
Kennedy who doesn't drink
the comedian shares tons of praise for
executive producer Lauren Michaels Pete
is there is there anything you're going
to miss about this place oh yeah Lauren
for sure he's amazing he always gives
the best advice really this is all true
advice that Lauren's given me
um I'll never forget this I called him
and said uh when I got engaged I said
Lauren I just got engaged to Ariana
Grande after dating for two weeks and he
said oh hold on for dear life
he ends his speech by getting
sentimental about his time on the show
she ain't us now always having my back
and allowing me to work on myself and
grow and you know thank you to Lauren
for never giving up on me or you know
judging me even when like everyone else
was and for believing in me and allowing
me to have a place that like I could
call home with the memories that'll last
a lifetime so thank you guys
after the broadcast Pete's girlfriend
Kim Kardashian shows her support in a
special way she shares a collage of
Pete's appearances on SNL to Instagram
he's just super genuine for Kate
McKinnon her special tribute actually
kicks off the big finales and you miss
Rafferty
yes same oh really
no obviously not
she reprises her close encounter
character one last time and Gibson out
of this world send off in the code open
I love you
thanks for letting me stay a while
live from New York it's Saturday night
congrats to the departing cast members
[Music]